الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها في استعراض
موحد للقوة التي تواجه عدوانًا من روسيا ،
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية هاري ترومان في أوروبا تعمل على
تحسين التعاون مع حلفاء الناتو
للتأكد من أن التحالف يمكن أن يعمل بشكل أكثر
تماسكًا ، كما تقول ضابطة الطيران البحرية
جانيت لازارو ، لقد ذهبنا للتو إلى هناك
للاندماج مع  شركاء الناتو المختلفين ،
أي شخص نعمل معه ونعمل
على تسهيل عمليات الاتصال نوعًا ما
حيث تواصل روسيا حشد
القوات بالقرب من الحدود مع أوكرانيا ،
وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنها ستساعد في تعزيز
تحالف الناتو بشكل أكبر ، وهذه هي المرة الأولى
منذ الحرب الباردة التي
تم وضع مجموعة حاملة طائرات كاملة تحت
قيادة الناتو مع سفن من دول الناتو المختلفة
التي تحيط
بالترومان ، وحافظت الولايات المتحدة على العلاج الأشعر في أوروبا
لفترة أطول مما هو مخطط له مع اشتداد المواجهة مع
روسيا لطمأنة
حلفاء أمريكا بأن الولايات المتحدة ملتزمة تمامًا
بالدفاع الجماعي روسيا  لقد حشد
أكثر من مائة ألف
جندي بالقرب من أوكرانيا كما تعتقد الولايات المتحدة
وموسك  يمكن أن يأمر بشن هجوم في أي وقت
بينما قال الرئيس بايدن إنه
لن يرسل لنا قوات إلى أوكرانيا ، حيث
يستطيع هاري ترومان تحصين الجناح الشرقي لحلف الناتو بشكل فعال على
الرغم من الوجود البحري الكبير لروسيا
في البحر الأسود ، حيث
يمكن لطائرات حاملة الطائرات F-18 الوصول بسرعة إلى
منطقة قريبة من أوكرانيا
يقول قائد ترومان إن سنوات من
التكامل مع الحلفاء تؤتي ثمارها الآن ،
فنحن ملتزمون بتحالفاتنا
شراكاتنا ،
فنحن قادرون على تشغيل التوصيل والتشغيل
في أي مكان في العالم
ومن وجهة نظر العدو ،
نحن محايدون  إذا كانت لدينا شراكة قوية ،
فهذا أقوى مما
يمكن أن يكون أي خصم فردي ، حيث
تقول الولايات المتحدة إن روسيا ستدفع
ثمناً باهظاً لأي غزو إضافي
لأوكرانيا ، وقد أعلن البنتاغون للتو
أنه سينشر
قوات أمريكية إضافية في ألمانيا بولندا
ورومانيا  يتطلب الوضع الحالي أن
نعزز الموقف الرادع والدفاعي
تجاه الجناح الشرقي
لحلف الناتو ، وقد كان الرئيس بايدن واضحًا أن
الأمم المتحدة  ستستجيب دولها
للتهديد المتزايد لأمن أوروبا واستقرارها ،
لكن الولايات المتحدة وحلفاءها يقولون
إنهم يأملون في أن تسود الدبلوماسية حيث لا تزال واحدة
من أقوى قوات الردع الأمريكية
في حراسة فريد ليتكن سي إن على متن سفينة
هاريس ترومان الأمريكية في البحر الأدرياتيكي.